-(cheering, applause)
-Welcome back.
Now, tonight we have to talk
about the latest
police shooting video
that's making national news.
Police in Louisiana
this morning
are investigating the deadly
police shooting of a black man.
NEWSWOMAN: The video apparently
shows police confronting
37-year-old Alton Sterling
Tuesday morning.
He's tackled
by one of the officers.
Seconds later, an officer
appears to scream out,
"Sterling is holding a weapon."
Sterling was pronounced dead
at the scene.
He was pronounced dead
at the scene
because he was shot by the cops
while he was pinned
to the ground.
I mean, when I saw this video,
like many of us in this office,
I mean, we were all
just speechless.
I mean,
is this the type of thing
we should really have
on a comedy show?
Now, we've covered
this type of thing in the past,
and to be frank with you,
we're just tired
of this (bleep) happening,
and feel like we have
to address it in some way.
And let me just say, thank God
for (bleep) cell phones.
(applause, whooping)
Really. Because...
we would never even hear about
incidents like this otherwise.
In fact, part of what makes
people in the black community
so enraged about this is,
for years we never had evidence
for these things.
But, you know, in Baton Rouge,
the cops have body cameras.
Okay. So let's see
what that shows. Roll it.
NEWSMAN:
The officers in question
were wearing body cameras,
but they apparently fell off
at the altercation.
-Fell off?
-MAN: Fell off.
Things don't just fall off.
Unless you're talking
about Sisqó
and face of the (bleep) earth.
All right? I mean, seriously,
Sisqó, where's "Thong Song 2"?
(laughter, groans)
I don't know,
this looks bad, Louisiana.
And they know it looks bad, too.
They even brought out
the governor to talk about it.
The video is disturbing,
to say the least.
In Louisiana,
we're known for our ability
to come together
in difficult circumstances.
We will certainly get through,
uh, this tragedy.
Okay, seems like
they're taking it seriously.
I mean, he's got
more middle-aged black women
on that stage than
a community theater production
of The Color Purple, so...
-(laughter)
-Right? Right?
Kudos, kudos, kudos to you.
Right.
But, uh...
but what does the, uh,
Louisiana governor
specifically have to say
about the investigation?
There should be no, uh...
doubt in anybody's mind
but this incident
is gonna be investigated
impartially,
professionally and thoroughly,
uh, by the United States
Department of Justice
Civil Rights Division.
Wait, hold on a second.
The Department of Justice?
The same Department of Justice
that just handled
Hillary's e-mails?
I don't think black people
are waiting for these cops
to be excused because the FBI
says they were just "careless."
And what gets me about this,
what really gets me,
is that whenever this happens,
there's always
an immediate takedown
of the dead man's character.
We do understand he did in fact
have a criminal record.
According to his family and some
of the records that we dug up,
yes, he did have at least...
at least one prior conviction.
NEWSWOMAN:
Sterling has an arrest history,
ranging from battery
to drug possession.
So he had a criminal record.
Martha Stewart has
a criminal record.
-(laughter, applause, whooping)
-I don't...
I don't remember her
being executed
in a convenience store
parking lot.
Maybe I missed it,
but it feels like
that would have made
Huffington Post at least.
No matter what his crimes were,
Alton Sterling did not deserve
to be executed for them.
Look, guys, the punishment
for resisting arrest
shouldn't be death.
The punishment
for selling bootleg CD's
shouldn't be death.
The punishment for having a gun
in an open-carry state
shouldn't be death.
The punishment
for being a black man
shouldn't be death.
(applause, whooping)
Now...
Black Lives Matter protests
have already sprung up
across Louisiana
in the past 24 hours,
and, you know, let me just say
a quick word about this
just for a second.
It's not that black lives are
more important than white lives,
or Asian lives,
but all people don't have the
same uniquely fraught history
with law enforcement
that black people do.
This is why as infuria...
infuriating as it was,
that black people cheered for
the O.J. Simpson verdict, okay?
Long before white people
could give an Emmy
to Sarah Paulson's hair.
(laughter)
So when Black Lives Matter
is protesting,
can we just not hear this
right now?
This theme
of Black Lives Matter--
you know what also matters?
Blue lives matter.
And all lives matter.
Absolutely, all lives matter.
-Black lives matter because
all lives matter. -Mm-hmm.
-All lives matter.
Black lives matter or all lives?
Well, they say
black lives matter.
I and you and Donald Trump say
all lives matter.
Okay.
If you really believe in
"all lives matter"-- it's fine--
then you should be out there
protesting, right?
-I mean, Alton Sterling...
-(applause, cheering)
If you break it down.
Alton Sterling was a life,
the loss of which
should upset you.
You know what?
I'll tell you what.
In the spirit of inclusuvity...
inclusivity,
let's check in
with an All Lives Matter,
uh, rally here in New York.
(cricket chirping)
I'm sorry, that's our bad.
Um, that's right,
uh, maybe All Lives Matter is
protesting in Chicago. Our bad.
(birds chirping)
That was my bad again.
Uh, All Lives Matter must be
protesting in Louisiana.
I mean, that's where the murder
happened. If you could just...
(cricket chirping)
Where's the outrage, guys?
I thought
all lives mattered to you.
Doesn't Alton Sterling's
life matter?
We'll be right back.